on est à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de l'endroit où le pipeline de transgene
abouti c'est un pipeline qui va
transporter trois fois plus de pétrole
des sables bitumineux d'ici deux à trois
ans et les gens ici s'inquiètent ils
s'inquiètent de l'augmentation du trafic
maritime de pétroliers et il s'inquiète
aussi de l'impact sur les épaules ars et
orques qui sont en voie de disparition
[Musique]
on va suivre la biologiste mexy mcdo
fille qui va nous amener dans l'habitat
essentiel de ces or pour comprendre
quelle est leur fragilité et sa clique
alors deux navires comme celui là il y
en a à peu près 250 chaque mois qui
passe dans ce secteur de l'île et avec
le pipeline trans mountain
on s'attend à 35 navires pétroliers qui
s'ajoute à chaque mois
[Applaudissements]
m
depuis le début de l'été il ya des
nouvelles règles les bateaux ne peuvent
plus s'approcher à moins de 400 mètres
des orques alors qu'avant c'était 100 m
mais évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à respecter pour les grands
navires on est ici dans une des zones
qui identifiés comme les plus à risques
de déversements de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de tonnes de pétrole et la
compagnie a dit que c'était plausible
mais hautement improbable